[Music]
[Applause]
suppose the two American friends are
traveling together in Italy they go to
see Michelangelo's David and when they
finally come face to face with the
Statue they both freeze dead in their
tracks the first guy we'll call him Adam
is transfixed by the beauty of the
perfect human form
second guy we'll call him bill is
transfixed by embarrassment it's staring
at the thing there in the in the
center so here's my question for you
which one of these two guys was more
likely to have voted for George Bush
which for Al
Gore I don't need to show a hands
because we all have the same political
stereotypes we all know that it's uh
that it's bill um and in this case The
Stereotype corresponds to a reality it
really is a fact that Liberals are much
higher than conservatives on a major
personality trait called openness to
experience people who are high on
openness to experience just crave
novelty variety diversity new ideas
travel people low on it like things that
are familiar that are that are uh safe
and
dependable if you know about this trait
you can understand a lot of puzzles
about human behavior you can understand
why artists are so different from
accountants uh you can actually predict
uh what kinds of books they like to read
what kinds of places they like to travel
to and what kinds of food they like to
eat once you understand this trait you
can understand why anybody would eat at
Applebees but not anybody that you
[Applause]
know this trait also tells us a lot
about politics the the main researcher
of this trait Robert McCrae says that
open individuals have an affinity for
Liberal Progressive left-wing political
views they like a society which is open
and changing whereas closed individuals
prefer conservative traditional
right-wing views this tra also tells us
a lot about the kinds of groups people
join so here's a description of a group
I found on the web
what kinds of people would join a global
Community welcoming people from every
discipline and culture who seek a deeper
understanding of the world and who hope
to turn that understanding into a better
future for us all this is from some guy
named
Ted well let's see now if openness
predicts who becomes liberal and
openness predicts who becomes a tedster
then might we predict that most teders
are liberal let's find out I'm going to
ask you to raise your hand uh whether
you are liberal left of center on social
issues we're talking about primarily or
conserv I'll give a third option CU I
know there a number of Libertarians in
the audience so right now please raise
your hand down in the simal cast rooms
too let's let everybody see who's here
please raise your hand if you would say
that you are liberal or left of center
please raise your hand high right now
okay please raise your hand if you'd say
you're
libertarian okay about a two dozen and
please raise your hand if you'd say you
a right of Center or
conservative 1 two 3 four five about
eight or 10 okay
this is a bit of a
problem because if our goal is to
understand the world to seek a deeper
understanding of the world our general
lack of moral diversity here is going to
make it harder because when people all
share values when people all share
morals they become a team and once you
engage the psychology of teams it shuts
down open-minded
thinking um we when the liberal team
loses as it did in 2004 and as it almost
did in
2000 we Comfort ourselves
we try to explain why half of America
voted uh for the other team uh we think
they must be blinded by religion uh or
by simple
[Music]
stupidity
so okay so if you think if you think
that half of America votes Republican
because they are blind in this way then
my message to you is that you're trapped
in a moral Matrix in a particular moral
Matrix and by the Matrix I mean
literally The Matrix like the movie The
Matrix um but I'm here today to give you
a choice you can either take the blue
pill and stick to your comforting
delusions or you can take the red pill
learn some moral psychology and step
outside the moral Matrix now because I
[Applause]
know okay I assume that answers my
question I was going to ask you which
one you pick but no need you're all High
openness to experience and besides it
looks like it might even taste good and
you're all epicures so anyway let's go
with the red pill let's take let's study
some moral psychology and see where it
takes us let's start at the beginning
what is morality and where does it come
from the worst idea in all of psychology
is the idea that the mind is a blank
slated at Birth developmental psychology
has shown that kids come into the world
already knowing so much about the
physical and social worlds and
programmed to make it uh really easy for
them to learn certain things and hard to
learn others the best definition of
innateness I've ever seen this just
clarifies so many things for me it's
from the brain scientist Gary Marcus he
says the initial organization of the
brain does not depend that much on
experience nature provides a first draft
which experience then revises built-in
doesn't mean unmalleable it means
organized in advance of experience okay
so what's on the first draft of the
moral mind to find out um my my
colleague Craig Joseph and I read
through the literature on anthropology
on cultural variation IM morality and
also on evolutionary psychology looking
for matches what are the sorts of things
that people talk about across
disciplines that you find across
cultures and even across species we
found five five V matches which we call
the found the five foundations of
morality the first one is harm care
we're all mammals here we all have a lot
of neural and hormonal programming that
makes us really bond with others care
for others feel compassion for others
especially the weak and vulnerable gives
us very strong feelings about those who
cause
harm this moral Foundation underlies
about 70% of the moral statements I've
heard here at Ted the second Foundation
is fairness reciprocity uh there's
actually ambiguous evidence as to
whether you find reciprocity in other
animals but the evidence for people
could not be clearer this Norman
Rockwell painting is called the Golden
Rule and we heard about this from Karen
Armstrong of course is the foundation of
so many uh religions that second
Foundation underlies the other 30% of
the moral statements I've heard uh here
at Ted third Foundation is ingroup
loyalty you do find groups of uh in the
animal kingdom you do find Cooperative
groups but these groups are always
either very small or they're all
siblings it's only among humans that you
find very large groups of people who are
able to cooperate join together into
groups but in this case groups that are
united to fight other groups this
probably comes from our long history of
tribal living of tribal psychology um
and this tribal psychology is so deeply
pleasurable that even when we don't have
tribes we go ahead and make them because
it's
fun
um Sports is to War as pornography is to
sex we get to exercise uh are some
ancient ancient drives uh the the fourth
Foundation is Authority respect here you
see submissive gestures from two m a
very closely related species but
Authority in humans is is not so closely
based on on Power and brutality as it is
in other primates it it's based on more
voluntary difference and even elements
of Love at
times the fifth Foundation is Purity
sanctity this painting is called the
allegory of Chastity but Purity is not
just about suppressing female sexuality
it's about any kind of ideology any kind
of idea that tells you that you can
attain virtue by controlling what you do
with your body by controlling what you
put into your body and while the
political uh right May moralized sex
much more uh the political left is
really doing a lot of it with food food
is becoming extremely moralized nowadays
and a lot of it is ideas about purity
about what you're willing to touch or
put into your body I believe these are
the five best candidates for what's
written on the first draft of the moral
mind I think this is what we come with
at least a preparedness to learn all of
these things but as my son Max grows up
in a liberal college town how is this
first draft going to get revised and how
will it end up being different from a
kid born 60 M south of us in Lynchberg
Virginia
to think about cultur variation let's
try a different metaphor If there really
are five systems at work in the mind
five sources of intuitions and emotions
then we can think of the moral mind as
being like one of those audio equalizer
that has five channels where you can set
it to a different setting on every
channel and my colleagues Brian nosic
and Jesse Graham and I made a
questionnaire which we put up on the web
at uh www.y yourmorals.org and so far
30,000 people have taken have taken this
questionnaire and you can too here are
the results here are the results from
about 23,000 uh Americans citizens on
the left I've plotted the scores for
liberals on the right those for
conservatives in the middle of the
moderates the Blue Line shows you
people's responses on the average of all
the harm questions so as you see people
care about harm and Care issues they
give High endorsement of these sorts of
statements all across the board but as
you also see liberals care about it a
little more than conservatives the line
slopes down same story for
fairness but look at the other three
lines for liberals the scores are very
low Liberals are basically saying no
this is not morality ingroup Authority
per this stuff has nothing to do with
morality I reject it but as people get
more conservative the values rise we
could say that liberals have a kind of a
two channel or two Foundation morality
uh conservatives have more of a five
Foundation or five channel morality we
find this in every country we look at
here's the data for 1100 Canadians I'll
just flip through a few other slides the
UK Australia New Zealand Western Europe
Eastern Europe Latin America the Middle
East the East Asia and South Asia notice
also that on all of these graphs the
slope is steeper on ingroup Authority
Purity which shows that within any
country the disagre isn't over harm and
fairness everybody I me we debate over
what's fair but everybody agrees that
harm and fairness matter Moral Moral
arguments within cultures are especially
about issues of ingroup authority Purity
this effect is so robust uh that we find
it no matter how we ask the question uh
in one recent study we asked people to
suppose you're about to get a dog you
picked a particular breed you learned
some new information about the breed
suppose you learn that this particular
breed is independent minded relates to
its owner as a friend and an equal well
if you're a liberal you say hey that's
great because liberals like to say fetch
please
but if you're conservative that's not so
attractive if you're conservative and
you learn uh that a dog is extremely
loyal to its home and family and doesn't
warm up quickly to strangers for
conservative well loyalty is good dogs
ought to be loyal but to a liberal it
sounds like this dog is running for the
Republican
nomination so you might say okay there
are these differences between liberals
and conservatives but what makes those
three other foundations moral aren't
those just the foundations of xenophobia
authoritarianism and puritanism what
makes them moral the answer I think is
contained in this incredible cryptic
from heronimus Bosch uh The Garden of
Earthly Delights in the first panel we
see the moment of creation all is
ordered all is beautiful all the people
and animals are doing what they're
supposed to be doing where they're
supposed to be uh but then given the way
of the world things change we get every
person doing whatever he wants with
every aperture of every other person and
every other animal uh some of you might
recognize this as the'
60s but this the 60s inevitably gives
way uh to the 70s where uh the uh
cuttings of the apertures hurt a little
bit more of course BOS called this hell
um so this this tryptic this these three
panels portray the Timeless truth that
uh order tends to Decay the truth of
social entropy but lest you think this
is just some part of the Christian
imagination where Christians have this
weird problem with pleasure here's the
same story the same progression uh told
in a paper that was published in nature
a few years ago in which uh Ernst fair
and Simon gar had people play a common
dilemma a game in which you give people
money uh and then on each round of the
game they can put money into a common
pot and then the experimentor doubles
what's in there and then it's all
divided among the players so it's a
really nice analog for all sorts of
environmental issues where we're asking
people to make a sacrifice and they
themselves don't really benefit from
their own sacrifice but you really want
everybody else to sacrifice but
everybody has a temptation to free ride
and what happens uh is that at first
people start off reasonably Cooperative
this all played a anonymously on the
first round people give about half of
the money that they can uh but they
quickly see you know what other people
aren't doing so much so I don't want to
be a sucker I'm not going to cooperate
and so cooperation quickly decays from
reasonably good down to close to zero
but then and here's the trick far and
gar said on the seventh round they told
people you know what new rule if you
want to give some of your own money to
punish people who aren't contributing
you can do that and as soon as people
heard about the punishment issue going
on cooperation shoots up it shoots up
and it keeps going up there's a lot of
research showing that to solve
Cooperative problems it really helps
it's not enough to just appeal to
people's good motives it really helps to
have some sort of punishment even if
it's just shame or embarrassment or
gossip you need some sort of punishment
to bring people when they're in large
groups to cooperate there's even some
recent research suggesting that religion
uh priming god making people think about
God often in some situations leads to
more Cooperative more prosocial
behavior um some people think that
religion is an adaptation evolved both
by cultural and biological evolution to
make groups cohere in part for the
purpose of of trusting each other and
then being more effective at competing
with other groups I think that's
probably right although this is a
controversial issue um but I'm
particularly interested in religion in
the origin of religion and in what it
does to us and for us because I think
that the greatest Wonder in the world is
not the Grand Canyon the Grand Canyon is
really simple it's just a lot of rock
and then a lot of water and wind and a
lot of time and you get the Grand Canyon
it's not that complicated this is what's
really complicated that there were
people living in places like the Grand
Canyon cooperating with each other or on
the savannas of Africa or on the Frozen
shores of Alaska and then some of these
Villages grew into the mighty cities of
Babylon and Rome and Teno Tian how did
this happen this is an absolute Miracle
much harder to explain than the Grand
Canyon the answer I think is that they
used every tool in the toolbx it took
all of our moral psychology to create
these Cooperative groups yes you do need
to be concerned about harm you do need a
psychology of justice but it really
helps to organize a group if you can
have subgroups and if those subgroups
have some internal structure uh and if
you have some ideology that tells people
to suppress their carnality to pursue
higher nobler
ends and now we get to the Crux of the
disagreement between liberals and
conservatives because liberals reject
three of these foundations they say no
let's celebrate diversity not common in
group membership they say let's question
authority and they say keep your laws
off my body liberals have very Noble
motives for doing this traditional
Authority traditional morality can be
quite repressive and restrictive to
those at the bottom to women to people
that don't fit in so liberals speak for
the weak and they want change in Justice
even at the risk of chaos if this guy's
shirt says stop bitching start a
revolution if you're high in open to
experience Revolution is good it's
change it's fun conservatives on the
other hand speak for institutions and
traditions they want order even at some
cost to those at the bottom the great
conservative Insight is that order is
really hard to achieve it's really
precious and it's really easy to lose so
as Edmund Burke said the restraints on
men as well as their Liberties are to be
reckoned among their rights this was
after the chaos of the French Revolution
so once you see this once once you see
that liberals and conservatives both
have something to contribute that they
they form a balance on on change versus
stability then I think the way is open
to step outside the moral
Matrix this is the great Insight that
all the Asian religions have have
attained think about Yin and yangang Yin
and yangang aren't enemies yin and yang
don't hate each other yin and yang are
both necessary like night and day for
the functioning of the world you find
the same thing in Hinduism uh there are
many high gods in Hinduism two of them
are visher the preserver Shiva the
Destroyer this image actually is both of
those Gods sharing the same body you
have the markings of Vishnu on the left
so we could think of Vishnu as the
conservative God you have the markings
of Shiva on the right Shiva is the
liberal God and they work together you
find the same thing in Buddhism these
two stanzas contain I think the deepest
insights that have ever been attained
into moral
psychology uh from the Zen Master San if
you want the truth to stand clear before
you never be for or against the struggle
between for and against is the mind's
worst disease unfortunately it's a
disease that has been caught by many of
the world's leaders but before you feel
Superior to George Bush before you throw
a stone ask yourself do you accept this
do you accept stepping out of the battle
of Good and Evil can you be not for or
against
anything so what's the point what should
you do well if you take the greatest
insights from ancient Asian philosophies
and religions and you combine them with
the latest research on moral psychology
I think you come to these conclusions
that our righteous Minds were designed
uh by Evolution um to unite us into
teams to divide us against other teams
and then to Blind us to the
truth so what should you do am I telling
you to not strive am I telling you to
embrace senson and stop stop with this
struggle uh uh uh for and against no
absolutely not I'm not saying that this
is an amazing group of people who are
doing so much using so much of their of
their talent their Brilliance their
energy their money to make the world a
better place to fight to fight wrongs uh
to to solve
problems but as we learned from Samantha
power in her in her uh story about
Sergio uh Via de de Mayo you can't just
go charging in saying you're wrong and
I'm right because as we just heard
everybody thinks they are right a lot of
the problems we have to solve are
problems that require us to change other
people and if you want to change other
people a much better way to do it is to
First understand who we are understand
our moral psychology understand that we
all think we're right and then step out
even if it's just for a moment step out
check in with
senson step out of the moral Matrix just
try to see it as as a struggle playing
out in which everybody does think
they're right and everybody at least has
some reasons even if you disagree with
them everybody has some reasons for what
they're doing step out and if you do
that that's the essential move to
cultivate moral humility to get yourself
out of this self-righteousness which is
the normal human condition think about
the Dal Lama think about the enormous
moral authority of the Dal Lama and it
comes from his moral
humility so I think the point the point
of of my talk and I think the point of
the point of Ted is that this is a group
that is passionately engaged in the
pursuit of changing the world for the
better people here are passionately
engaged in trying to make the world a
better place but there is also a
passionate commitment to the truth and
so I think the the answer is to use that
passionate commitment for to the truth
uh to try to turn it into a better
future for us all thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
m